today's video is sponsored by
squarespace so we will hear more from
them at the end
i think you're the hottest one we have
so i appreciate you
oh okay i can agree to that you gotta
know this chess situation and that cute
pink's got
yeah bruce is hot he's our local baby
i'm gonna go pick up those
loot drops with the 4x4 truck i want
everybody to know
bruce i hope you know that we're sharing
that truck we are sharing the truck and
i will hand it to you to
give the hot chick what she wants shut
up oh
come on buddy come on god bless the fun
bims for this
anybody wants uh i got big ol
like cyber goth raid boots i feel like
i feel like bruce should have those oh
yeah yeah could you send me a picture of
this yeah
any love i'm unattainable even though
i'm unassuming
remember that yeah you just need a nice
guy maybe you're just dating [ __ ]
maybe if you dated the right kind of guy
then you wouldn't have that attitude so
yeah it's actually you're the problem
not me i'm actually i'm a pretty nice
guy you know
would somebody mind coming with me on my
uh my quest in the morning
yeah yeah i'll come with you it was
scary out there but i would like to go
back there to get my stuff
yeah let's go i'll follow you oh you
want to go now
it's night time you know what i'll
follow you and i'll protect you
[ __ ] all right god no she's the perfect
woman
help john help me oh he's at home
[Music]
you know john i think i can handle this
you know um i think that i'll be fine if
i'm the one who saves the hot chick
you could go you could go do something
else like i could
yeah i could maybe rescue her and hop in
all right
hey how are you doing hey
what have you been up to i am not your
object all right
look but have you seen the socks with
your [ __ ] chest
how do you even drive just because i was
well endowed doesn't mean
i am your object i just asked how you
were doing jesus
fine oh dawg oh my god
oh dog oh what the [ __ ] bruce
no bruce did you run over the dog
literally beeline to run over the dog
what the
[ __ ] you gotta run it over again
oh my god oh no
oh my god oh so unnecessary
stupid air dropping [ __ ] roof outside
there's so much hot one that crazy
whoa i heard zombies what the [ __ ] noise
is that big boy
big boy with a hat big boy with a hat is
it cool is he a cool guy
is he coming off to bruce don't touch my
things
oh my god
hey bruce do you ever you haven't got
sweaty these bamboo sheets these bamboo
sheets last night
oh do you have to like sleep naked
because i got something when you sleep
why do you oh yeah because i was just
wondering
my gosh i'm so excited i know me too i'm
getting
really i'm really like i'm not even
scared i'm just excited yeah
you should be scared bruce yeah same i'm
not scared of the bruce
i'm not i'm not i don't get scared
actually so
uh we'll be fine hey bruce just letting
you know
like i just like i plant trees on my
weekends like in my spare time
i'm doing it right now actually i don't
know why are you i actually
want to join i kind of have no respect
for anyone except you know those who
earn it
and i damn you sasuke
hey my number dave call me sometime [ __ ]
all right that's all my gas so i'm gonna
save the rest of the gas for the
for the um i would i would uh
i would slide my uh balls across
uh an ocean full of broken glass
just to um get a hint of
oh your gas is that ee coming
[Laughter]
oh hey oh fancy seeing you here spikes
are the worst
uh hello alana hey what would you like
from me
oh no i was just saying
i haven't done that in hours actually so
all right
but it's also not my fault you look that
way i'm gonna actually
run and grab that actually that's like
right around the corner
no not i'm gonna take my sweet truck um
it's got dumps like a truck truck truck
hey are you talking about me again
what oh my god i'm so nervous guys hey
bruce do you need anything do you need
anything like any you need any like help
with anything or
like are you asking you know just
wondering one hour away
you know because i'm nice i'm just
trying not to get in my way while i'm
killing
all the zombies sick this [ __ ] guy
is cool so cool actually
we're the turret boys we don't really
need you i'm kind of just getting our
way
john what kind of stuff there's a lot of
broken glass in the clapping box
it's a 128 times wow
i don't know if you know that 256 times
though wow
that means that bruce is the best shot
of out of everyone because he has the
biggest skill all right well i could
have told bruce that you
i don't know that you needed to say that
cover me guys i'm going out and looting
okay i would love to call you where are
you going do you need help i can help
you
what's the west side no no we're good oh
you know alana you could just show up
and be like
i didn't know you were here oh we had
two coincidences i didn't know that
you're outside
no one no one can argue with that really
if you just show up somewhere and you're
like wow what a coincidence
anyway let's hang out that's true yeah
oh my gosh nice shot whoever just shut
that guy's arm off
um for his head but you're welcome oh
um my knee is skinned but i'm coming out
oh are you okay do you
need do you need any help with that i
don't need any help oh
yeah i'm down here you're way down there
oh my gosh
come check out my hold over come check
out my whole time
can you guys wait till i get back
i could be right there and i could check
help you with that check that out maybe
it's all mine oh oh yeah oh
oh oh backflips yeah i'm doing it on
purpose
super cool uh single if you're
interested bruce um
yeah i i could backflip in my plane
i'm doing great hey i'm having a great
day it's also the way they jump
out here having fun it's right there
just put one of their legs out it's so
weird
like it's very ballerina-esque
i well my viking is a lady after all oh
we have a woman on the server hey what's
up
i gotta hit on you again like the last
time we played a survival game together
it's not my fault she's hot that's true
a lot of defense
oh my god careful bruce i i'm going to
continue to call you done york
because i think it's called mythology
better york
yeah it means uh eat ass and vikings
yeah do you need i volunteer as tribute
hey this is a really nice date that
we're on right now if
you know oh wow where everybody can see
like are you single or
like what's up uh when i heard a rumor i
heard remember that you wanted to vote
me out of the island is that true
no i would never m'lady i wanna put you
put your bronze on my chest
i don't you know you know what i'm
saying uh oh hold on lana do you get it
this is flirting with you this is the
father this is the furthest i've ever
made it with you
oh my gosh jeez
oh gosh you want some ooh from patrick's
drawers
i'm ready to adventure
oh damn hey girl oh let me see what i
need hey what's up
how are you doing i'm gonna make two
special eyes up here how high i jump
leather scrap is that all right eyes up
here
i'll take anything i can get here i'll
drop it's a mating dance
okay let's hang on if we press jump at
the same time
three two one go oh that did not work
three two one
i jumped on top of you yeah that's what
i'm talking about though
yeah so chuck smart poker what is it
was that it was that you were trying to
show me no no no hold on i thought i got
on this i got to get on this one
but now i'm like i'm probably going to
die oh
no oh no oh my angel
baby no oh my gosh don't look at my body
and you're right it is gosh i mean it's
a bit if you do if you want dressed that
way bruce then maybe
i will you know okay i'll let myself on
fire
all right the stairs are difficult to
get up i will so it's very
really hard it makes no sense for that
difficulty yeah
oh my god girl the way you you jump is
just
so much stress i ain't never seen nobody
jump like that before in my life
oh i do work out every single day i work
i do squats
oh and what else is sexy mostly
we like hip thrusts we like watching hip
thrusts lunges
uh-huh keggles giggles
get kegels yeah make sure not to jump
off the boat
i don't have confidence in my ability to
pick anybody up yeah that's true
no no absolutely not it's awful don't do
that
not that i would know actually it's
never it's never influenced me
negatively but i've heard
from all this guys i saw carowind die on
the ocean no you didn't
shut your beautiful beautiful mouth
the rumors were true okay that's so big
and on fire
i'm baking the ass right oh my god
there's so many little guys around here
too are you okay bruce are you uh
do you need any help at the moment are
you okay
we're gonna look really good today yeah
oh yeah this is whatever nice workforce
oh yeah i saved you again i saved again
no no work i'm good
i have a boyfriend i have a boyfriend
where is he why would you say
somebody if you have a boyfriend but
where is he so that's what i'm saying oh
where is he oh he's i mean like he's at
home
yeah we just slayed him right now yeah
yeah
i mean you can look you i mean if you
say if you're saying i'm lying there you
call me a liar is that what you've done
i would never no i don't think they're
not capable of that
so uh jacob are you getting like wood
and stuff i want to go check his cave to
see if there's any loot
that's a good call let's loot that cave
how do you come up with so many good
ideas this is what i adventure
just like do you just just come back
oh boy okay i must eat food
just be ready can i get you anything you
need
anything no i have my own food leave me
alone
i have a boyfriend i don't see him so
this is it
oh what does he go to another school
yeah do you live in canada
no i have a boyfriend the bad news is i
don't know how to help you anyway
perfectly honest i'm gonna go check that
troll cave again
oh okay okay my love be safe give me
with a thumbs up
so are we getting on the boat yes we are
all right
but now i'm terrified of drowning to
death so don't worry be okay
i'll grab your hand carowind
i'll grab your hand touch it i'll grab
your ass didn't you work
hey cause let people just take it all
and put it in storage so lawrence
doesn't have to swim
okay please don't let me die either hold
on okay
i will never i would never straighten
back out again
you'll be okay repeatedly telling me
that i can't eat certain foods is kind
of my favorite
i know but you can't eat more sausages
uh we don't actually do anything hang on
wait are you saying that everyone else
eats your ass except me
maybe what the [ __ ] i mean i'll take it
a special treatment it's cause she's in
it for the long game
it's gonna be her ass eventually hello
everybody i hope you enjoyed the video
but for now
i need to tell you all that squarespace
gives people a powerful and beautiful
online platform from which to create
a website you can connect with your
audience and generate revenue through
gated members only content manager
members send email communications and
leverage
audience insights all on one easy to use
platform
you can see how your visits unique
visitors and page views trend over time
gain insight into the top traffic
sources products device types browsers
and operating systems by visits
you can also extend squarespace's
already powerful ecommerce abilities
with squarespace extensions
you can also and this is the thing that
made me think that talking about
squarespace would be
really useful for my audience
automatically push website content to
your favorite social media channels so
your followers can share it too
but also so that brands can potentially
see it this is literally how i got
started in games media
i wrote all my stuff on a blog when i
was just starting out writing articles
basically by myself in some cases
and then i manually made sure to tweet
all of them so people knew that i was
writing and that i was available for
freelance work
with squarespace you can do that all
automatically and it's a great way to
get involved in games media if you're
looking to start out
so go to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.compears to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain